Welcome to Google
Developers Hackademy.
This is the second part
of the Android SDK
introduction course,
created by Enrique Diaz
from GDG Androidtitlan Mexico.
If this is your first contact
with the course,
I recommend you watch
the first part
and do the exercises.
Hi. Welcome to lesson 2.
My name is Enrique Diaz.
Remember in the previous lesson
we learned 3 important things
about Android framework.
First, we went through its
history and where it comes from.
Then, we analyzed statistics
and the growth it's had.
And finally, we got excited
by the relevance
and potential the platform has.
In this lesson we'll learn
5 very valuable things.
First, we'll learn how
the Android framework works.
Second, we'll check
the structure of an application.
As third point,
we'll check out Dalvik Debug
Monitor Server
and what it is for.
What's more, we'll see
Android SDK Manager
and we'll finish by creating
a virtual device
with Android Virtual
Device Manager.
"Knowing Android framework."
In the API's lowest part
we find six very important
components it inherits
directly from Linux Kernel.
The first one's called
"wakelocks,"
and what it does, basically,
is prevent battery waste
by automatically
turning the display off.
This means that, natively,
Linux doesn't have it,
however,
Google developed it
particularly
for mobile platforms.
Two: "low memory killer."
This is a process that allows us
to automatically eliminate
applications
we're no longer using,
so we have enough memory space
to open other apps.
Three: "binder."
This is a process called
within Java classes
built on the top of the stack.
Its goal is to maintain
memory space
that are assigned as resources
to be able to have and create,
whether it's other activities,
intents or services.
Four: "ashmem."
This is a process that allows us
to create memory spaces
that are both shared between
the OS and the final user.
Five: "alarm."
This process comes
from Linux Kernel
and allows us to maintain
the status of a clock.
It inherits from Real Time Clock
and as it is, it's the phone's
alarm and internal clock.
And finally, six: "logger,"
which is a process
also from any operative system
that allows us
to be sensing and recognizing
what is send as a message
in the OS console.
The biggest difference
in Android is that,
instead of using sockets,
it uses buffers.
This means you can access
this content
in real time.
Another important part
of the API are the libraries
that, despite not being entirely
developed by Google,
allow to add functionality
to our applications.
There are 4 important ones
I'd like to mention:
"open SSL,"
which allows us to have
certain security and ciphering
for the applications.
"Sqlite," which is a tool
to create databases in Sqlite.
"WebKit," which is
another library
that allows us
to natively implement
the WebKit browser.
And finally, "Bionic,"
which is the C compiler
that is used instead of GCC.
Dalvik Virtual Machine,
unlike any other
virtual machine,
is register-based.
This reduces in 30%
the size of our executables.
In a normal Java environment,
in Java language,
we have .class files,
which are executed
through the Java Compiler.
Passed through the Java process
they can be executed
in Java's VM, very differently
to how you'd do it
in a Dalvik VM
because you have a .class file
that goes through
the DEX process
and are turned into Dalvik code.
The last part of the API
is something you can access
from Java code
that allows us to create
our own applications,
and besides,
access system services
with just one codeline.
Two examples: one can be
Notification Manager,
which allows us
to create notifications,
and Power Manager,
which allows us
to turn the display on and off
at our own will.
Finally, the last layer
within our stack
are applications themselves,
whether we build them
or are downloaded
from Google Play.
LET'S GET TO WORK
Now we will see
the file structure
in an Android project,
and this is important so you,
as a programmer, can understand
which files you need to modify.
Here, on the video,
I already have a project
I have initialized.
So we go to Source folder,
then to the package
mx.androidtitlan.holamundo,
and we can see something called
"MainActivity.java" inside.
This is a Java file,
just like that,
the difference is
it inherits from Activity,
which is the class
we will see later on,
and it has two
very important methods:
onCreate and
onCreateOptionsMenu.
We won't get into details now,
we'll continue seeing
the rest of the files.
We'll enter a folder called gen.
In it we can see there is
a BuildConfig.java,
which clearly tells you
not to modify it.
This is useful
because, when you're building
an application for Android,
it automatically builds
this file,
because it allows us
to be in control.
And the R.java file
manages images and dependencies
in our project.
Pay close attention
to this part because,
if you notice,
we have the attributes part,
dimens part,
drawbles part,
IDs, layouts, menus,
strings parts.
All these elements
are assigned to a memory space
that Android
automatically controls.
Pay special attention
to this Easy Launcher,
because we will see it
later on and we'll understand
what the Android framework
does internally.
Now, we can check
the API for version 4,
where it allows us
to add functionality
towards previous versions
of Android SDK.
We're also entering
the bin folder,
where, basically, there are
files generated by the framework
which are executable.
We have the res folder,
which contains nothing now,
and also another file
called AndroidManifest.
And the folder libs,
which we're now seeing,
has nothing but
another .jar file,
which is the dependency
we previously checked.
It is also very important
because here we have
all the resources of our project
and the resource concept
in Android is very simple:
everything which is not
a Java file
is a resource.
Whether it's in .xml files,
files that give architecture
to the way we see our app,
selectors, buttons, etc., etc.
For example, here I'm seeing
ic_launcher.png,
and if you remember well,
in the R file,
we had just that variable.
And what is the framework doing?
Defining a memory space
to have control of that file
and then show it
in our application.
In this folder, layout,
we have a file called
activity_main.xml,
and, as you can see,
it's a graphical interface.
It's important here
to understand that an .xml file
allows us to have
an user interface
and manipulate and create
elements with which
the user will interact.
Also, in the menu folder,
we have an .xml folder
called menu,
which we won't see
in this lesson.
In values,
we have three .xml files:
dimensions, strings...
Also,
in this other identifier,
in the sw600dp suffix,
it basically helps us
maintain control
over devices
with different densities,
in particular,
the sw600dp suffix
is trying that all those
dependencies, in dimensions,
are usable in 7-inch tablets.
And the same for sw720,
just that here it's the
particular dependencies
for 10-inch tablets.
The suffix values-v11
allows us to have control
over values
within a particular API,
in this case is version 11,
and for version 14
it's exactly the same,
but for API level 14.
And finally, we open
AndroidManifest.
In the file AndroidManifest
we have
the entire description
of our project
and, specially, I am opening
the Manifest file
is probably the most important
file of the project.
If you look closely,
we have several tags,
such as package,
version code
and version name.
For example, version code
is very important
for Google Play because
it allows it to understand
if there are any updates.
The version name is a string,
a mere text,
and it allows us
to have internal control
in a development team
and to know which version
we're working on.
It also defines
the SDK minimum version
and what the target is.
In this sense,
the minimum version allows you
to discriminate all devices
that don't have that version.
Below we can see
the class application,
and inside is the class
activity. These are tags.
In the case of application
we see
if it allows it
to make a backup,
what's the icon to be shown
in our launcher,
the tag and the theme.
By default, since I'm taking
Hola Mundo as it is,
I'm not adding any properties.
When I create a new project
this is how it should appear,
and inside the app we have
another tag called activity.
This activity is the definition
for all our activities
or classes we have
in our application.
Now we will access
the proguard-project.txt file,
which somehow helps us
cipher our project
and add a layer...
a security layer
to our Java file.
In this case, as you can see,
it's briefly explained
what it does
and, broadly speaking,
it's rules
that help us be in control
on the Java code side,
to which reverse engineering
can not be applied.
And finally, we have
project.properties,
which is a file that helps us
have control
over the dependencies
management.
Up next,
we'll see Android Virtual
Device Manager,
which is a tool that allows us
to logically test
different configurations
for our application.
In the Android Virtual
Device Manager section
we have a window that pops up
and lets us visualize
some important things.
We have em16, for example,
em16, -1, -2, -4,
etcetera, etcetera.
Each one of this is a nave
for our virtual device,
and all that column
allows us to know their name
to be easily identified.
It also contains target name,
which is the API level
for which this virtual device
is designed.
It also contains the platform.
In the first 3 cases it's 1.6.
The one below is Nexus_4,
which has 4.3 as platform
and it's Android 4.3.
The API level,
which is the next column,
and it varies from one
to the other.
As you know, we have
the newest one to date,
which is API level 18.
And finally, we have the CPU,
the ABI,
which is the processor
on which we run our emulator.
In the first few cases
it's an ARM,
and in the last ones
it's an 7a version ARM.
In the device definition tab
we can see a list,
which contains
the virtual devices
that Google facilitates
by default.
The upper part of it
contains, for example,
Google's Nexus S.
This is a real device
that is used to be able
to do our tests here.
This device, Nexus S,
has a 4-inch display
with 480 x 800 dimensions
and an hdpi display
with 343 MB in RAM.
Now we will create
a new virtual device.
It will display
a series of elements
that we can modify,
and we can also choose
by default
which device
with its different properties.
We can choose
if we want a front camera,
a back camera,
how much RAM memory...
if it's going to contain
an internal storage device
or an SD card.
We hit start
in the virtual device...
and there it is.
Android SDK Manager
is a tool that allows us
to download
the newest API versions.
Besides, it allows us access
to a source code,
to documentation and libraries
that the API doesn't have
by default,
such as Google Play Services,
the tool for charges
within the platform,
and many more.
Now we will enter
Android SDK Manager,
which contains a series of files
that we downloaded
to the repository
that Google provided us with
to use and implement
new versions of the API
into my projects.
Here we can see
the window has shown up...
and what we can see first
is the Tools folder,
which contains the tools
to developing,
including also
the Eclipse plug-in.
In this case we have
Android SDK Tools
and, specially, in this video
we can see we have
an update available,
which is version 22.2.
Besides, we can see
all versions
for the current APIs,
including the documentation,
the platform, the samples,
the emulator
for the two kinds of processors,
ARM and Intel x86,
the Google APIs
and the source code.
For all versions of the API,
from 17 to 4.
And another
very important folder,
within SDK,
is Extras, where we have
some libraries
not natively contained
in the framework,
like for example
Google Analytics SDK,
or AdMob Ads SDK.
Also Android Support Library
and Google Play Services.
Up next,
we'll see Dalvik Debug
Monitor Server,
which is a series of tools
that help us control
and simulate
functionalities
inside our virtual device.
Things like making a call,
receiving an SMS
or simulating longitude
and latitude values
are some of the things
you can do with this tool.
Finally, we will enter
Dalvik Debug Monitor Server.
In this window we can see
all the processes that are
running in my emulator
in this device section.
This processes, as they are,
are those that are running
as part of the operative system.
Also, at the top,
we can see several tools
to finish the process,
performing a checkup,
emptying the Heap,
performing a debug,
etcetera, etcetera.
And, specially, there are two
of them that are very important,
like this one in particular
called Device Screen Capture,
that allows us to take
a snapshot of the application
and of the current device
that is connected
to our SDK tool.
In this section we can see
different tabs
that help us check
the status of the application
that we are running.
We have, for example, Threads,
Heap, Allocation Tracker,
Network Statistics,
File Explorer
and Emulator Control.
We're specially
interested in two,
which is File Explorer,
where, as we can notice,
there is a file system
which is just the one
Android contains,
and Emulator Control,
that allows us to check
and simulate some calls
or SMS
and also to control
the 3G data
it can receive and sense,
as well as the protocol
and speed at which it goes.
Besides, in Telephony Actions
I can add
a number and simulate an SMS
by adding a message.
Such as: "Hey, nice course,"
which I can send...
and, in my emulator,
it should show
as a sent message.
We can see it there.
It's an SMS we can open
and reply.
And we can also make a call,
just by switching the button...
and we should be able
to see it in our emulator.
There it is,
with the number 1337.
You can also simulate
that you hung up
and it will show up
as a missing call.
Finally, we will check
the Log window,
which outputs information
from the operative system
or from an application
we develop.
As you can see from the video,
we have a little text column
which is outputting
all the messages
from the Dalvik Virtual Machine
such as a garbage collector,
or the activity manager.
Let's recapitulate.
One:
we learned how Android
framework works.
Two:
we went through
the file structure of a project.
Three:
we used Dalvik Debug
Monitor Server.
Four:
we checked what is
Android SDK Manager.
And, finally, five:
we used Android Virtual
Device Manager.
In the next lesson we will see
three very important things:
one, we will learn
what an Activity is.
Two, we'll implement an Intent.
And three, we will learn
what a Fragment is.
My name is Enrique Diaz.
Keep on programming!